today well let's see today we're going
to talk about this is the second lecture
in the series of three just to recap
from last week we looked at briefly why
businesses might be interested in
biodiversity and ecosystem services and
we looked a little bit at how companies
can understand their links to
biodiversity and ecosystem services
measure the strength of those linkages
value those linkages using some of the
economic valuation tools that you've
you've heard about and report on those
those linkages and the their impacts
their dependence and their responses to
biodiversity loss what I'd like to do
today is talk a little bit more about
what companies can do to reduce the
damages that they cause to avoid or
mitigate risks and also on the plus side
what are the opportunities for
businesses to make money or improve
their their performance by conserving
biodiversity or supplying ecosystem
services or restoring ecosystems as the
case may be and this corresponds to
chapters four and five of the the teeb
for Business Report now this is not a
new agenda this is a famous cartoon from
40 years ago 1971 the first Earth Day I
don't know how many of you know about
pogo pogo swen tout of production a long
long time ago Walt Kelly is no longer
with us but it has the famous line we
have met the enemy and he is us which
you must have heard of and basically I
think this encapsulate a couple of
things firstly the value of nature the
beauty of the forest primeval as
porcupine says and also the threat to
that from our consumer lifestyle the
waste and other pollutants and damages
that result from meeting human need
and human aspirations and the question
then is how do you first of all reduce
that damage but also find the business
opportunity in reducing that damage
there's an old saying I think where
there's muck there's brass I don't know
where that comes from the UK probably
but the idea is that there's always a
business opportunity even in something
that seems very unlikely such as a mess
in the forest so let's first of all look
at the the mitigation side what can
companies do to reduce damages and there
are many many tools that have been
developed over the last few years I
don't have time to go into all of them
but broadly I think you can categorize
the different approaches to helping
businesses first of all avoid negative
impacts secondly reducing those impacts
or mitigating them and thirdly verifying
how well they're doing this and we
talked a little bit last time about the
the weaknesses of self certification by
business that they often need Outsiders
objective authorities to verify what
they're doing and just a few examples
among the many that are out there and
that are explained along with many other
examples in the tube for business report
firstly on the avoidance side the
integrated biodiversity assessment tool
is basically a geographic information
system developed by Conservation
International with a lot of other
business partners and IUCN and unep
World Conservation monitoring center to
basically provide companies with
geographic information about where our
biodiversity values hi or at risk so
that they can avoid those areas in their
site selection processes and that sort
of as far upstream as you can get trying
to avoid the footprint before it takes
place and plan around that and secondly
their whole range of tools available
that businesses have developed
themselves or have developed in
partnership with others to try and
reduce damages or mitigate impacts and
I've highlighted one that I've been
involved in recently called the business
and biodiversity offsets program which
focuses on compensatory mitigation so
what do you do you've caused some damage
you can't avoid it completely what do
you do about it how do you measure your
residual footprint and and compensate
for that and I'll come back to that and
lastly as I mentioned and as we also saw
last week there a whole range of
initiatives that allow companies to
certify their performance and allow
consumers investors and others to
discriminate when they're making their
their consent product purchasing or
consumption choices now I want to focus
a little bit on biodiversity offsets
partly because I know a bit more about
it but also because i think it lies on
the cusp between impact mitigation and
business opportunity and I'll explain
why in a few minutes so what is Beebop
Beebop is a multi-stakeholder initiative
and many of these tools are the product
of so-called multi-stakeholder
initiatives government's business NGOs
community-based organizations getting
together around to try and find a
solution to a problem and this
particular initiative is administered
out of a US based NGO called forest
trends but it's really owned by all the
partners in in the program and
essentially what it tries to do is
ensure that when businesses undertake to
compensate for residual damage to
biodiversity they do it in a credible
way in a systematic way and in a
verifiable way and they've developed a
whole range of documents and tools to to
do that now where do offsets fit in the
business response to environmental
damage people often refer to the the
mitigation hire
our key with the environmental
mitigation hierarchy is a sort of basic
conceptual framework for understanding
how companies relate to biodiversity and
ecosystems and you can see on the left
hand side of the graph there's an impact
whether it's from digging a mine as in
the case of Rio Tinto they produce this
this graph or building a parking lot or
residential development or a golf course
or what or even a farm there's an impact
it's usually negative relative to the
baseline not always but that's what
we're mostly concerned about and as I
said you can avoid some of that damage
you can minimize that damage you can
even rehabilitate after the project is
complete after the construction is done
after the mine is closed you can try to
restore native vegetation and create
habitat that is conducive to the species
that were there before or perhaps even
species that weren't there before but
could thrive in that location but even
after all those steps there's usually a
residual there's a certain quantum of
damage that you can't get rid of and
that's where the biodiversity offsets
come in it's an attempt to try to say
okay we know those residual damage we
can never get back to where we were
before so we're going to take undertake
some other actions that would provide
some compensation that would replace the
goods and services the ecosystem
services that were lost as a result of
this residual impact and then on top of
the offset there may be some other
activities that company supports or that
any organization supports in relation to
that project such as environmental
education where you can't trace the
benefits directly in the same terms to
abolish the outcome but we know it makes
a positive contribution institutional
capacity building might be another
example of a additional conservation
action that would be supportive but that
is not as measurable as an offset
attempts to be so let's look a little
bit more closely at offsets and at Rio
Tinto this is a company that in 2004
under
pressure from NGOs and and others and
thanks partly to the the leadership of
their their senior executives decided
that they were going to try and have a
positive impact on biodiversity which is
a very unusual thing for a mining
company to promise given the nature of
their business but as it says their aim
is to ensure that biodiversity and
conservation ultimately benefit from
their presence in a region so it's a
very it's a heroic ambition it's an
aspiration and they would certainly not
claim that they have achieved it or yet
but they're trying to take steps in that
direction and a first step towards that
was understanding what is their
biodiversity profile what is their
footprint and so they undertook a
scoring across all of their sites around
the world to identify those sites that
are have relatively high biodiversity
value low or medium or very high and
they rank them and that was just a
simple priority setting exercise based
on various indicators sort of
conventional indicators of biodiversity
value not so much economic as ecological
so looking again more closely at the the
offset component of the business
response there's a definition that
results from many years of work you'd be
surprised how much effort went into the
few words on the screen and that again
is a reflection of this
multi-stakeholder approach it's typical
that you have to get a lot of people
around a table for a long time
wordsmithing to get agreement on on a
definition and this essentially says
that biodiversity offsets about
compensating for significant residual
adverse biodiversity impacts and each of
those words is meaningful the
significant matters view why bother
offsetting insignificant damages
residual points to the fact that you
only take undertaken offset offset after
you've gone through the whole the rest
of the mitigation hierarchy you've
avoided and minimized and rehabilitated
as much as possible an adverse of course
recognises that biodiversity impacts are
not always negative but we're
mostly concerned with offsetting the
negative ones and I think the second
sentence of in the definition is also
important because it makes it clear that
it's what we are trying to offset what
are the impacts and it's not just in
terms of ecological impact species
composition habitat structure Equus but
also ecosystem function and the use and
cultural values that people obtain from
biodiversity so that adds to the
ambition of an offset and that you're
not simply trying to replace the
ecological values but also some of the
economic values associated with those
resources and work is still ongoing to
figure out how to do this in practice
now I realize that offsets are
controversial in some quarters this is
about carbon offsets but I think the
same concern applies in some people's
mind to a biodiversity offset or a water
quality offset and the cartoon is as you
can see is basically suggesting that you
can get a credit for not causing damage
that you can get you ought to get paid
for in action and to be honest this is
what red is about to it's the idea that
you should be rewarded for not doing
something and that is it's awfully
difficult to determine whether somebody
would have done something anyways and
whether their inaction is really a
positive contribution in some way and
this dilemma effects discussion about
biodiversity offsets just as it does
carbon offsets notwithstanding that
concern people are moving ahead quite
quickly to develop methods and tools and
techniques to deliver biodiversity
offsets and I want to distinguish here
between three sort of broad categories
firstly there's the the one-off
case-by-case offset you have a project
creates damage you measure that impact
that footprint and you compensate for it
and that's usually done and I
like-for-like basis you try to replace
the ecosystem or the
system services that were lost and it's
often done as a on a kind of bilateral
basis a negotiation between the project
developer cause of the impact and local
communities or local government but then
there are other variations there's
biodiversity trading and biodiversity
banking and the idea of trading is
simply that the offset is not
necessarily provided by the person
responsible for the damage but it may be
provided by a third-party those
transactions have to be verified and
they have to be legal so in France for
example where they've been developing a
biodiversity offset and trading regime
they are constrained by French law which
does not allow you to transfer legal
liability for damages so the developer
retains responsibility for the offset
even if they find a third party to carry
out the compensation action that's not
the case in common law jurisdictions so
you have to look at the legal situation
to understand what's feasible
biodiversity banking is a third or I
suppose a more evolved version of this
arrangement whereby you do the offsets
in advance and you get credits in
advance for providing ecosystem services
compensation benefits those are verified
again by some credible agency usually
government who issues credits to the
entrepreneur who's undertaken this
restoration and then the entrepreneur
needs to turn around and sell those
credits to recoup their costs from a
project developer so this is its pecky
its environmental speculation in a sense
you go into a region where you think
there's going to be some damage you
acquire land you restore it you get the
government to give you credits for that
restoration and then you sell those
credits later on to developers who may
be coming into that area and it can be
quite profitable wetland mitigation
banking in the United States as an
example of that but there are other
examples around the world
okay why would people be interested in
banking seems like a elaborate exercise
to go through well I think the the basic
argument is that you get better outcomes
for biodiversity as a result so if you
just do a case-by-case offsets what
you'll find is that the offsets are
developed and implemented in relation to
the specific project but not in relation
to each other and the net result after
the development process is completed is
you have a patchwork of offsets all over
the landscape which may or may not
deliver the same kind of biodiversity
outcome that you would get if you
planned ahead and so the idea of banking
is you can use good land use planning
figure out where you want the mac to
maximize your ecological benefits where
do you want your biodiversity secure
those assets first and then allow
development to take place around that
and as we know from ecology connectivity
and scale are very important features in
providing biodiversity benefits so the
patchwork may not deliver what we need
and banking is one way to to get around
that problem so what are we banking what
are these credits based on this is still
not economics but there have been many
people working for many years on trying
to define these values and indicators to
measure them and within the the business
environment its program they've looked
at intrinsic values which most
economists would argue don't exist use
values and cultural values and these are
loosely based on the millennium
ecosystem assessment but not identical
and as I said that first column I
suppose that's from my perspective it's
a it's a recognition of the fact that
conservationists are particularly
concerned about certain aspects of
ecosystems and certain species and they
want to make sure that those values are
retained irrespective of whether they
have any use value or non-use value or
cultural value to human
and they look at different levels at
species habitats and landscapes now when
you're doing an offset calculation you
need to come up with a quantitative
measure and the the usual way that the
bebop program tries to do this is to
estimate what they call habitat volume
so they look at changes in habitat
condition over time as a result of the
project and so if you look at the top in
the the red figure you have a loss
occurring quite soon after time zero
that's the project impact in this case
it's a land clearing loss and you need
to not only look at the area but also
the quality of the habitat that is lost
as a result and then they look at the
offsets and there are two ways to look
at this one is just look at improvements
above the baseline that's above the
dotted line in the on the left hand side
but you can also look at avoided risk
and this is again similar to read which
you heard about I guess so last week if
you can quantify the extent to which you
are avoiding a measurable risk of
biodiversity loss then you can perhaps
claim credit for that avoided risk and
again you need to look at the quality
changes in habitat associated with that
how do we look at the quality changes
again there's there's a lot of work
going into coming up with ecological
indicators to measure changes in sight
condition and also to account for the
linkage between a particular site and
the wider context and a few examples
here these are hypothetical but they've
been used in the field in some places
the the images on the right are actually
from South Africa so typically you start
with a benchmark site you want to
understand what is the reference site
condition
of biodiversity against which we're
going to measure pluses and minuses and
in this case in South Africa was a large
platinum mine they found a relatively
healthy ecosystem fairly dry so not a
lot of vegetation but that's the natural
condition and then they compared that to
the site that was going to be mined
that's number two which was degraded
because they'd been a lot of livestock
on there and you need to take account of
the difference between the reference or
benchmark site and the project site
because you've already lost some quality
that isn't necessarily attributable to
the development project three is well
what happens after the project that's
the hole in the ground and that that one
is about three kilometers long by a
kilometer deep it's a big mess and of
course there's not a lot of biodiversity
in that hole so you then need to measure
the distance or in or the difference
between two and three to get an estimate
of the project impact and then four is
again a hypothetical estimate of what
you would achieve afterwards through the
restoration actions that you would take
on the offset site not in the mind
you're not doing this in that hole but
in an adjacent plot of land that
provides similar services or better
services so essentially what you're
trying to do is take something that
looks like to turn it into four and
measure the the improvement against one
and you're also taking account of the
impacts in in three sorry if that's not
immediately clear but if you go to the
bebop site you'll get more guidance than
you can possibly stand okay lots of
issues around offsets it's not it's not
necessarily the best thing since sliced
bread and there's a lot of controversy
around it people often ask you know when
is an offset appropriate are you allowed
to negotiate between avoidance and other
forms of mitigation and offsetting and
and there's a strong view in the
conservation community that you should
only allow an offset at the
very end of the mitigation hierarchy
from an economic perspective that's
questionable because the avoidance has a
cost the mitigation has a cost the
offset has a cost and you need to trade
off the costs and benefits of each of
those stages and there may be situations
where you would accept a little bit less
avoidance or a little bit less
mitigation in favor of more offset
because of the what the net benefits
delivered will be but as I say that's a
controversial point who wins and who
loses is a major concern if you offset
on-site even very close to the project
site it's not necessarily the same
communities who are losing and gaining
so if ecosystem services are important
here and the offset site where you're
trying to do the compensation is say
five kilometers down the road it's a
different community that's benefiting
from those services than the one that
lost them what's the currency another
concern is like for like always better
now I go back to the case of the
Platinum Mine in South Africa they were
looking at compensating for loss of some
dry land rangeland some scrub nice stuff
but there's a lot of it not particularly
threatened in a South African context
meanwhile 10 kilometers down the road
there was a wetland under severe
pressure which might have been a higher
priority from a conservation perspective
so should they have put the offset
effort there instead of into restoring a
an ecosystem that isn't so threatened
what are the limits of responsibility
should the company be responsible for
what happens after the product has left
their facility for consumption or
distribution impacts can we design an
offset that would say for palm oil
consumption that consumers might
purchase that would account for the
impacts of palm oil production way
upstream
and of course there are a lot of issues
around governance security land rights I
talked about the example of France
financing a very often offsets will be
set up with a insufficient funding the
developers say well will sponsor the
creation of NGO will set up a little
trust fund to manage this area in
perpetuity and people quickly discover
that the trust fund is inadequate the
offset is starved of resources and it
fails so this is a common problem also
as we've seen in the united states with
wetland mitigation banking enforcement
matters you may get approval for your
credit but if nobody comes back five
years 10 years 20 years down the road to
ensure that you're still delivering
those services then you failed and in
many cases government agencies
themselves are underfunded and they
don't have the resources to go around
and check all these offsets year after
year after year but if you don't do that
then it's a temporary offset so lots of
issues and people working on trying to
deal with these and the bebop is
probably one of the more advanced
efforts to try and deal with these and
they've they've come up with a set of
principles for what is a good offset
starting with the biodiversity impact
that it actually delivers no net loss of
biodiversity that the impacts are
additional you may have heard of this in
the context of carbon offsets as well it
can't be business as usual but you have
to be able to show that this wouldn't
have happened otherwise adherence to the
mitigation hierarchy this is what I
referred to the idea that you only do
the offset at the very end of the
response to impact limits to what can be
offset very important again to many of
the conservation NGOs involved in this
and quite rightly they feel that certain
things are not offset able you don't
replace extinction is forever as they
say so you don't replace a species that
you've made extinct and you also don't
replace or compensate for a significant
loss in the
range of a highly threatened species so
there a certain irreversible impacts
that should not be offset and and should
not occur in the first place landscape
context is what I mentioned early about
taking account of where offsets sit in
the wider landscape and what's going on
in the landscape because ecosystems are
not static and lots of other things are
happening besides the project
participation in social equity as you
would expect with any multi-stakeholder
initiative is essential and that
includes business participation just as
an aside the people running the bebop
program have recently started working
with governments about setting up
policies and laws on offsets and
business members of the bebop networker
concerned to say the least about how
that's going ahead and what's their role
in a regulatory reform long-term
outcomes refers to this issue about
enforcement and perpetuity transparency
is a sort of a motherhood and apple pie
we all look for that science and
traditional knowledge is an interesting
one it's the idea that you not only look
at what the mainstream academic
scientists are telling you about
biodiversity and its value but you also
take account of indigenous and community
concerns and in some situations those
may not be coincident and so you need
some way to factor in indigenous
preferences and values sacred sites
being an obvious example maybe that's
not offset able okay let's come back to
economics it's a little bit of an aside
on biodiversity offsets what's the
current state of thinking and what's one
of the major initiatives trying to do
but if we're looking at this from an
economic perspective as we do in T we
need to translate all those ecological
indicators of biodiversity and ecosystem
services back into economic values and
of course so we're starting as usual
with the biophysical and then using
various valuation methods to get to
monetary values
not always necessary but it's a major
part of what teeb is about and I'd like
to talk a little bit about a case study
in Madagascar again Rio Tinto an apology
is for all the Rio Tinto stuff but
that's what I've been working on
recently this is an ill amide mind which
elimite is an ore that's used to produce
titanium dioxide goes into paints white
paint in particular you can't have
without titanium dioxide and various
other industrial products they have
found a huge reserve of it in madagascar
they have permission to mine that in
conjunction with their policy of trying
to achieve a net positive impact on
biodiversity they've undertaken some
biodiversity assessment sense and
conservation actions including support
for the creation of a protected area in
a forest one of the largest remaining
tropical forests in Madagascar that's a
near their mind site and originally they
were thinking that they would use this
as part of their offset as part of their
effort to achieve net positive impact in
the end they didn't need it they found
other sites that were better that were
more like the impact sites and they used
those instead I think they ended up
using about a thousand hectares of this
60,000 as part of the overall package
but broadly it was it was considered as
an option and once they'd started they
didn't want to back out they wanted to
follow through with the conservation
investment yes
the latter category potentiality you can
be resized I had that will be impacted
even wanted three wait
it was more the former because at that
stage they were not looking at economic
values they were trying to follow the
more strict biophysical definition of an
offset so they were looking for similar
soil similar vegetation similar
elevation similar structure and you know
coming back to what I said earlier
that's when conservationists talk about
offsets those who are willing to talk
about offsets and many are not they want
to talk about ecological like-for-like
not economic like-for-like but it's an
interesting point i'll come back to that
in a moment so while i was at iucn a
colleague of mine and i and some others
worked with Rio Tinto to try and
understand what were the costs and
benefits of this conservation action and
the pretext for that it was it was
interesting the the company felt that by
conserving this forest they would have
more than enough to offset and they were
right and they thought okay could we get
credit for that if there was an offset
trading scheme in Madagascar how much
would those credits be worth and it was
kind of a an intellectual exercise for
the company they didn't think they were
actually gonna be able to sell credits
but they wanted to get to grips with the
way these systems work in a major
project that they had and so they wanted
to understand what would be the value of
the biodiversity benefits generated from
this action in economic terms and if
there's really two ways to look at that
you can come at it from a cost side and
say what does it cost you to produce a
credit and or you can come at it from
the benefit side what are the what's the
willingness to pay what are the values
generated by that that action and we did
both of them in this case so what we did
broad terms was try to estimate the
value of expected changes in ecosystem
service
in business as usual for continued
degradation of this forest vs a
conservation scenario that made certain
assumptions about what would be achieved
by the company's support and by
government action to designate a
protected area we looked at existence
values we looked at constant soil
conservation values impacts downstream
on agriculture water supply and the role
of forests in that recognizing that
that's a little controversial carbon
storage we also looked at bioprospecting
and eco-tourism but in the end we
weren't convinced enough by the numbers
that were coming out to include them in
the analysis but we didn't need that as
you'll see and of course we looked as I
said at the cost side what does it cost
to set up but also to manage a protected
area and importantly what are the
benefits for gone to the local
communities or others from not using
this forest as they have been using it
historically as an agricultural reserve
as a source of non-timber forest
products as a source of timber and I
want to focus on some of the estimates
and the methods that we use to come up
with these and for those who may have
downloaded the slides before this
lecture apologies i've added to them
partly with pavan's encouragement that
you like the detail so i'm going to give
you some of the detail so let's look at
existence values first at all and I
should preface that this case like the
1i presented last week used benefits
transfer we did not go out to Madagascar
and undertake original surveys and in
particular if you're looking at
existence values global existence values
you'd need to do surveys of everybody in
the world or a representative sample of
everybody in the world and we didn't
have the time or the funding to do that
I think you can get a long way with
benefits transfer you don't get all the
way but you can get a good first
indication and that may be enough to
stimulate more action more investment by
the company and generating better data
and we've seen that in other cases like
the wholesome example I presented last
week if you can provide
some initial preliminary estimates then
the company may be prepared to put more
resources into further research and
refining those estimates so what we did
on existence values well we started with
a previous study in Madagascar by the
World Bank Kramer and Mercer it's Randy
Cramer now at Duke looking at the
willingness to pay of us residence for
the conservation of an additional five
percent of the world's tropical forests
so they tried to look at a marginal
change and you'll know from your
valuation lectures that you don't try to
value the whole thing you value an
incremental change a marginal change
because that is going to be more
reliable than trying to value everything
they obviously looked at the number of
households in the united states having
carried out their survey and they
envisaged in this survey actually that
was a follow-up paper envisaged setting
up a fund based on that willingness to
pay so typically in a contingent
valuation exercise as you will know you
need a payment vehicle you need a way
that respondents can understand that if
they did pay where would that money go
and in this case that was the idea of
setting up a conservation fund and there
were certain assumptions about the
interest that would be generated by that
fund the income a range of estimates
using the usual sensitivity analyses you
divide through by the area of tropical
forests you take five percent of that
you look at the income from the fund and
you come up with an estimate US dollars
per hectare per year 1997 values between
about 2.6 and 3.9 u.s. dollars per
hectare per year that's for us residence
so what David Pierce and his co-author
did was then extrapolate to the rest of
the OECD it's a very simple
back-of-the-envelope calculation and
came up with an estimate of between just
about 17 and
five US dollars per hectare per year as
the existence value to households in
OECD relatively rich countries from
knowing that there would be a five
percent increase in the area of tropical
forests conserved
fairly modest you then just need to
adjust that for inflation and you come
up with the estimate that we used in
this case lots of assumptions here and
all of them are questionable but again
it's it's an attempt to try and get a
first preliminary indication of what's
the order of magnitude of this non use
value this existence value that people
talk about but very rarely measure and
we compared this to other estimates both
for Madagascar and for other countries
and it seems to be in the right ballpark
so we were willing to go ahead with the
lower bound estimate that might be more
speculative something that hopefully is
a little bit more grounded no pun
intended is erosion control looking at
what happens when you remove forest
cover to rates of erosion sedimentation
runoff and in particular the impacts of
that on agriculture downstream and we
had a range of estimates from Madagascar
of the area of rice paddies that could
be affected by deforestation around this
forest we had estimates from previous
studies of the impacts of siltation on
rice yields and rice production and
again in u.s. dollars per hectare per
year and we had our own assumptions
about how quickly this damage would take
place we assumed as an earlier slide
showed one to two percent deforestation
per year which was fairly modest but
historically supported rate and we
assume then that for every one percent
of the forest that is lost there's going
to be this downstream damage at value
that forty-four dollars per hectare per
year of forest that is to say so you
lose a hectare of forest downstream
impacts was estimated at $44 per per
hectare do a little bit of math across
those different areas of rice paddies
and you come up with an estimate of the
impact not huge
but worth considering then we looked at
carbon much easier because we've got
pretty good data on the carbon content
to forests in Madagascar we have good
canta on the content of the carbon
content of secondary forests that is to
save agricultural land and we can look
at the difference between intact forest
and agricultural land we have a lot of
estimates of the value of carbon ranging
from the price for red credits up to the
social cost of carbon did you cover the
social cost of carbon previously some of
you're nodding your heads again a simple
multiplication I should apologize for
the number on the bottom it's should say
1 point 7 45 not 1 comma 7 45 so it's 1
point 7 45 million estimate of the value
of avoided co2 equivalent based on a
one-percent deforestation rate and
valued at the low end of the the price
range for carbon as I said we looked at
the cost side and we looked at what are
the benefits of slash and burn or
shifting cultivation which is known as
tavi in Madagascar what are the benefits
that households derived from non-timber
forest products and what are the net
values of logging in that country and
all of these data come from existing
studies in in the country or even better
from in the region we tried to get as as
close as we could to the the project
site and similarly we had data from
Madagascar on the cost of establishing
and running a protected area you can put
all that together and I'm not going to
go through this table in detail times
moving on but just to mention that we
had to convert the carbon value and into
an annualized flow because when you look
at the the change it's a it's a it's a
stock change and we need to convert that
so it's comparable with these other
flow variables and I mentioned that
eco-tourism we had some data but it was
not on a per hectare basis and we also
concluded that any increase or change in
eco-tourism at that for a site which is
not a major tourism destination would
simply cannibalize visits to other sites
in Madagascar so there would be no net
gain there and bioprospecting this is
the the idea that there are cures for
cancer or other values in in in the
forest in wild species or in their
genetic material the problem there is
the range of values is so vast that we
couldn't reliably use it to to say much
at all and that is unfortunately an area
where we need much better research than
then we have put it together and you get
an estimate of net present value of
conserving this particular piece of
forest little over 17 million u.s.
dollars in net present value terms and
if you look at the chart you can see
that the biggest benefit by far is
carbon and this is in contrast to what
we saw in the case study last week in
the UK again we're looking at mature
tropical forest here rather than
wetlands in in the UK and you also see
that the biodiversity values are by
comparison relatively low and again
that's because you're spreading the
willingness to pay of households in the
OECD for global forest conservation
across all tropical rainforests
everywhere water supply and soil
conservation benefits are surprisingly
small and that may be the fact that this
is a sparsely populated area and
unfortunately the value of agricultural
production in this area is extremely low
these are very very poor people and so
there's an ethical issue here you might
have significant impacts on local
agricultural production and local
nutrition but because that is valued at
such a small amount it doesn't it
doesn't appear significant when you
compare it to some of these other global
values
such as OECD willingness to pay for
existence or the global markets
willingness to pay for for carbon on the
other side the biggest cost item is the
opportunity cost and that is the same as
we saw in the the wetland case from the
UK and I'll come back to a an obvious
implication of this but you might have
already thought of to do that though I
want to go briefly through some of the
positive side so what I've talked about
now is avoidance mitigation and offsets
as an example of a mitigation strategy I
I alluded briefly to the idea that
offsets might be tradable they might
generate value and that you can set up
businesses to do this I want to quickly
go through some of the other
opportunities that are there there are
many and this is one report among
several in the last few years that have
tried to identify how do you create
business value from conserving
biodiversity or providing ecosystem
services whether that's adding
biodiversity to an existing business
line or establishing entirely new
markets and so on the bottom right
you've got the examples of bio carbon
and red plus or water quality trading
biodiversity banking which I've referred
to where you're not just adding
biodiversity to something that an
existing product or service but creating
an entirely new sector adding
biodiversity to an existing product is
obviously easier you've got established
marketing and communication systems and
governance arrangements and probably the
best known you'll be know more about
this than I will since this is a
forestry school is for a certification
all right something like a quarter of
all global supply of industrial
roundwood is now certified under one of
these these various schemes we've seen
consolidation in the different schemes
so whereas ten years ago we had many
disparate certification schemes all
competing with each other now
were basically just have to and for a
stewardship council is the leading one
of those but we also have a problem in
that forest certification was basically
set up to deal with deforestation in the
tropics but that is not where it has
taken hold so most of the forest
certified are in temperate regions there
in Europe and at North America those
forests are important and it's good that
they're certified but this isn't where
the problem really lies other issues to
do with certification and labeling the
perennial one of regulatory capture how
do you ensure that the standards are
meaningful and that they are not
necessarily just designed to suit the
needs of industry this has been an issue
in the business and biodiversity offsets
program to you want business
participation but you don't want
business dominance how do you get wider
and faster uptake in a voluntary scheme
if people don't have to buy certified if
producers don't have to undergo
certification how do you how do you get
wider uptake and I think they're good
lessons to be learned from the FSC and
other forest certification schemes on
that and love takes a lot of effort
working particularly with retailers to
try and get commitments a so-called
buyers club for example and this is the
strategy adopted by my new employer WWF
which is to focus on those those
bottlenecks in commodity supply trains
where you get a concentration of market
power and if you can get them to change
their practices that spreads right
through the rest of the of the market
for similar reasons people focus on
Walmart huge buyer if you change their
buying practices you influence thousands
if not millions of suppliers that feed
their their system another issue a
perennial issue with all certification
schemes is the cost to small scale
producers and also the cost of meeting
the standard if consumers don't want to
pay so who pays for the higher standard
of a certification scheme ideally that
can
but not always possible consumers claim
they will buy green but only if it
doesn't cost them anymore in many cases
and that creates a problem because
you're just passing the cost back
upstream up the supply chain to the
producer and if those producers are for
example small-scale coffee producers or
in Latin America you're imposing an
additional burden on them and that they
may not be able to recoup through a
price premium a lot of governments have
tried to deal with that through aid
programs but that's very often not a
long-term sustainable solution which is
why many people look for regulated
approaches but that's for the next
lecture okay I've talked a little bit
about adding biodiversity to existing
products and services another approach
is to take those same negative impacts
and try to turn them into positives so
try to find a market opportunity related
to the adverse impact and this is from a
colleague in shell who's responsible for
their global environmental footprint and
trying to think about what are the
impacts of shale oil and this would
apply to any oil company and many other
companies as well and how can they turn
that into a positive so you start with
co2 emissions and we know that you can
turn that into a business opportunity
through offsets and you can get a
biodiversity benefit through bio carbon
offsets or through red schemes turns out
that she'll like a lot of these big
companies manages a lot of land and so
conceivably they can actually generate
carbon credits bio carbon credits or red
credits from the way that they manage
their land assets habitat disturbance
similarly we talked about offsets
conservation banking and trading schemes
here again shell holds a lot of land and
in some countries the regulatory
environment would allow them to get
credit for improved environmental
management on that land and
I spent some time with them in Colorado
looking at some land that they had
leased for natural gas production and it
turned out to be the habitat of the i
think that the black white footed ferret
or black-footed ferret i can't remember
exactly which one it's a critically
endangered species it's on the
endangered species list and they were
wondering well could they get some
credit by undertaking actions to improve
the habitat condition for this ferret
and also for some some birds that were
on the verge of being listed water use
you can look at payments for watershed
protection as a cost-effective means to
secure water supplies Marine footprints
is more complicated often because of the
the legal regime or lack of it but there
are some interesting examples looking at
how you manage oil offshore oil rigs to
get biodiversity benefits and there's an
example from another oil company in
Yemen that is finding that the
protection area they put around their
offshore rig has created an oafish down
and so you get more fish and you also
start getting other species colonizing
those rigs and similar example coming
back to shell they have major rigs in
the North Sea and there are questions
about what to do with them when they've
exhausted the petroleum reserves now
some people would say you should slice
them off at the base drag them back to
shore cut them into little pieces and
somehow make them go away or recycle
them that turns out to cost a fortune
billions of dollars so people are
considering are there other things that
you could do with a defunct oil rig that
would generate biodiversity benefit so
for example if you topple it over it
provides habitat for fish but it's also
no good for fishing because your nets
will get snared on the junk in the rig
corals will colonize it so there might
actually be a benefit from leaving the
rig in place now very controversial
there's a lot of pollutants associated
with those rigs as well I'm not saying
that's the answer but I'm saying people
are looking
at sort of cost-effective ways to
generate biodiversity value from oil and
gas production and other old
infrastructure pollution and waste of
course we've got recycling and various
tradable permit schemes and so on I
realize I'm probably starting to sound
like an apologist for the oil industry
or the mining industry and that's not my
intention but just to give you a flavor
of the kind of things that people are
thinking about in business and in some
NGOs that work with business I'm not
sure I readable this is but in T we
tried to come up with some rough
estimates of what are these different
markets how big are they now how big
could they become over the next 20 or 40
years and this comes from forests trends
which keeps and the ecosystem
marketplace which you may have seen it's
a interesting website they keep tabs on
these different markets and try to to
get a sense of what what's going on in
them and how quickly they're developing
you can see from this that certified
agricultural products are currently the
biggest and are expected to remain the
biggest area and I think that's maybe a
testament to the success of those
labeling and certification schemes but
you can also see projections of rapid
growth in some other areas just to
highlight here for example bio carbon in
red this actually could be well above 10
billion dollars a year but those were
the projections at the time and
certified forest products again expected
to increase dramatically even though
it's already a big part of the of the
the forest sector those are hypothetical
guesses at best for a range of
initiatives which sometimes are called
payments for ecosystem services I'm sure
you've heard about these and you
probably are familiar if you haven't
memorized the classic definition of
payment for ecosystem services put out
by span wonder
a little over five years ago a voluntary
transaction that's very important like
any market transaction has to be a
willing buyer and a willing seller for a
well-defined environmental service again
very important what exactly are you
buying and selling or a land-use likely
to secure that service which is a bit of
a get out clause if you can't quantify
the service itself you try to define the
type of land management practices or
marine ecosystem management practices
that would generate the services that
you're interested in you need at least
one buyer at least one seller and
conditionality is critical you don't get
paid unless you provide the service I
mean this is all sounds like any market
but from an environmental perspective it
was considered quite radical when the
concept was was put forward what does it
look like in practice this is from
Stefan padula at the World Bank he's
again been a leading thinker in what our
payments for ecosystem services and how
to implement them he's been doing it all
over the world for several years we have
this standard problem conventional
management of a resource generates a
certain level of benefit but imposes
external costs that the producer ignores
more sustainable management of that same
resource in the current market generates
less value and therefore it's not
favored the payment for ecosystem
service scheme simply says well if we
pay a supplement on top of the
conservation management what what is
already earned by conservation
management we can get resource users to
shift from the conventional to the
conservation management regime and
there's this trade-off between how much
or how little you need to pay the
minimum payment is the opportunity cost
to the resource manager of making that
shift from conventional to conservation
management the maximum payment is the
willingness to pay to avoid those
damages and that's where the negotiation
and issues of market power come in as to
who's going to get that that surplus I'm
not going to talk about the catskills
case because you've already heard about
it but just to mention
that although everybody talks about the
Catskills there are many many other
examples this is from France just near
where I was living and still living for
the next few weeks if y'all is a brand
you're probably familiar with they
discovered many years ago that there was
a threat to their water supply they
didn't call it payment for ecosystem
services they just realized that if they
wanted to protect the value of their
asset and their license to bottled water
they needed to deal with the threat the
threat was agricultural runoff and not
surprisingly they got in touch with the
local farmers union and with local
governments and came to a deal and I
don't know what price they ended up
agreeing but they came to a bilateral
deal with the the communities in the
upper watershed that supplies their
resource and it's a complicated chart
but it because it basically shows all
the different parties that need to be
involved in this this deal but another
example would be Perry AV tell another
well-known water brand they've also done
similar initiatives with farmers in
another part of France and you can find
examples in Costa Rica of a brewery that
have done similar deals so this is not
just the catskills although people like
to use that example because it's it's
relatively well documented okay one
question that people often ask about
payments for ecosystem services is what
does this mean for poverty reduction
particularly in developing countries on
the plus side there might be new sources
of income you might be able to diversify
your income and thereby reduce risks so
you're not just dependent on crop prices
or commodity prices but you have a
separate source of income that is
uncorrelated with those there might be
put opportunities to strengthen local
institutions as people start organizing
themselves around payment schemes and
learning how to manage resources in a
way that delivers ecosystem services
contributes to human capital formation
that's all fine but then on the
downside you can't sell what you don't
own and so if resource tenure is an
issue payments for ecosystem services
might be difficult to set up or those
people who don't have legal title may
not be able to participate the setup
costs can be quite substantial we've
seen that in many examples the capacity
of governments to monitor and enforce
contracts and sure that services are
being delivered and that people are
being paid for those services is not
always their corruption could be a major
issue but I want to highlight in
particular the issue of reduced access
to resources and reduce labor demand and
we've seen this even in the United
States they've been some interesting
studies looking at the Conservation
Reserve Program which is managed by the
US Department of Agriculture if you pay
farmers to take land out of production
to deliver ecosystem benefits or
conservation benefits you only have to
pay the farmer enough to make them
better off but remember the farmer is
looking at their net profits so you
don't have to pay for all the things
that a farmer has to do to generate
those net profits right farmers by seed
fertilizer machinery and all of those
things are provided by other people in
the local economy so if you pay the
farmer their net profits they're happy
and you get your conservation benefit
but the seed supplier the fertilizer
supplier the agricultural equipment
supplier and the person who maintains
the tractors they're out of a job and we
see that in other countries as well that
payments for ecosystem services can
deliver income to resource owners but
they can also undermine the rest of the
rural economy which is predicated on
certain production systems so you need
to think about how is the rest of the
rural economy affected by these these
new initiatives and I come back to the
Madagascar case where we have
potentially a very large carbon benefit
and potentially a significant
opportunity cost
loss of access to resources loss of
agricultural production and the obvious
response to that which you will have
thought of already is let's use the
carbon value to compensate for the
opportunity cost and so one of the
things that this company is looking at
now is how to capture that carbon value
through a red project how to set up a
scheme that would channel at least part
of that revenue back to the local
communities who are sacrificing their
access to this forest for the sake of
biodiversity it can work because in this
case the values in theory make that
possible whether it will work in
practice really depends as I said on a
lot of institutional factors the extent
of corruption which in Madagascar is
sometimes an issue and whether the
company is really is going to keep to
its word to to make this happen so
that's what I had prepared for today I
realize we've got about ten minutes left
and I'm happy to go back to any slides
or take any comments or questions I'll
start there